we did it I'm super excited traveler is
finally old enough to be able to wear
socks like me and so I finally got to
order him some Paul Smith's locks and
said they just shipped Paul Smith like I
did the stripey socks right but you do
often wear good socks I have noticed
that I that was some flexibility right
that I didn't think there was a chance
in hell of your sock approaching the
camera unless you went like seven feet
back I I will never be found without you
know that you know like your mom always
said you know don't don't ever wear
always had clean underwear you don't
know where you're gonna get to a car
accident
anybody else's mom say that [ __ ] because
what I did so my whole thing is like I
will never be in boring Sox's I think
life is too short for boring socks I
also have whenever I flew through London
it was a it became a thing that I would
always go there's a Paul Smith in
terminal 5 and I would always go that
Paul Smith buy a pair of socks and leave
it's just my stupid souvenir that I
would get and then once I had traveler
they baked insanely cute
baby clothes so I would go and I would
get something for traveller and so but
they didn't have socks and see cuz he's
just she was too small now because these
big-ass feet so I can finally get some
striking song Jordans and I'm very like
no not that I even ever wanted kids but
if I do I'm just very excited about the
idea of tiny baby Air Jordans how
quickly they'll be out of there five
bucks a pair or whatever and they're
like in them for two minutes I'm
confused though from your story Troy
because am I to gather that there was
once a time where we visited other
countries is that is that excit outdoors
it's 36 degrees in LA today 36 6 doing
your damn Celsius maybe it's not huge or
bad I could never
tell what buggers you're in Celsius
idiot used to track the first integer
and you add 32 it's very easy this
that's 72 minus 7 is 65 and you add 32
but that's it require me to do maths
pearce google it or i'ma have people
look it up but myself there's also
superior
and the quarters are this size great for
me with my mic is there alright I should
I should enter this thing yet me and
Troy we started we are hello everyone
welcome to a live episode of play watch
listen we're doing this celebrate 10
episodes I thought it would be a cool
treat for everyone for anyone who
doesn't know this is well it's basically
a games industry podcast we talk about
things he says I'm out of a certain
month and also Star Wars and weather and
other things Celsius vs. Fahrenheit all
the trending topics I did want to get on
top of the chat I am gonna be reading
your questions I've asked the other
story not to so that I can just like
carefully moderate but I'm basically
going to try to only read questions that
I actually related to whatever topic
we're talking about rather than just
making this whole thing and I think that
we would just never talk about any
actual topic but we do already have the
chat being like talk about Star Wars and
y'all try to try to make this already
that will happen like inevitably right
well look I mean enjoying Cornwall's ice
work I made a bet that Star Wars would
come up within the first 5 minutes and I
wouldn't do it so I want to bet what's
up Chad blow up what's the bet I just
wanna know Troy you ever made it past
the train and fall in order that's
that's that because that felt to me like
a boss battle like it was buggy it was
disappointing I know they've patched a
lot of that game at this point because
yeah I still haven't finished it I'm
very close though I'm the only one of us
that actually got to like a bat or
something like a big bat monster I mean
that was the point
spoilers sorry audience that's like the
bad thing is that like halfway but I got
way more of that game I still need I
mean I don't know it's hard to gauge cuz
I'm like the people this has to go back
and find all the doors that are you know
so good at different planets at
different times right so I feel like
that's confusing but yeah I think that
they patched a lot of the issues that we
should we do a reboot of our episode
reviewing that this game show at funny
house called Google Trends where I
basically pick any game or movie because
we have a movie show we talk about games
a lot obviously that's training in any
given month and I basically make like a
Google Trends related such guessing show
out of it be like what do you think has
been paired with this word picking the
topic this month because nothing is
coming out it was so hard I just had to
go with Netflix like usually I'd be like
sonic or Resident Evil or whatever but
just is just so little that's coming out
in May that that was like with the
trolls movie I think came out recently
but there's just nothing is happening
anymore it's this is a Mike Bethel
question but I always the nitrogen
please my game is mostly based on Colley
so if there's a book behind you by the
way that will answer this question oh oh
let's let's see if the magic bookshelf
could what's there historically games
did not come out this summer it was kind
of like the the myth of pilot season are
used to be that pilot season was a
certain amount of time like right in the
summer early early fall I remember as
late spring early summer where all the
networks were casting their shows for
all the shows to do shows are gonna come
out in the fall right so it was the same
thing with games no games were coming
out and like May June July because as I
understood it premiere
all of Europe was on holiday and nobody
would actually buy games is that is that
true am i or am I mistaken about that or
do you know why there's a lot of games
that come out in the summer because
that's like when we have summer
blockbuster movies that came out so why
not games I think my monkey story I just
looked I just thought do I have a book
about it um I think it was a bunch of
things so I think that's part of it the
the whole they think hobbies fiscal
years right like it's like you want your
game to sell a certain point in the year
so you you can post a good returns here
in your investors also Christmas is
still a massive reason Christmas you
know if you've heard of it people like
to buy things at that point in time they
love to buy things worked on a bunch of
games that that like especially on kind
of mid-sized indie titles where they are
trending towards being done by around
Christmas and then they basically just
sit on it because they know there's
gonna be a zillion things vying for
people's attention and they're like we
don't have the you know the we add vibe
sort of horsepower to fight against all
those other titles it also evolves right
like you had like definitely February
became this busy time because all gangs
that didn't make it out for their
Christmas release would launch like as
tightly before the fiscal years they
could and the other thing is is like
specific I think I feel like one of the
first was one of us was there was a Red
Faction game that came out like in the
summer and did really well and there is
ro the the open-world one but crucially
June Last of Us Rockstar law of Rockstar
Games come out in that period as well
like people buy out the room basically
and if you've got one big and this year
of course you know cyberpunk was was
intended for this kind of time you're
talking you're putting your hand up Troy
were you in were you in that red Red
Faction game was that was that Troy dude
because destroying buildings with a
hammer is fun ok I think that game is
super underrated it was me who plastic
Liam O'Brien played my brother
yeah dinner-plate Alec Alex Mason it's
true what they say all means not about
you Troy you're in absolutely everything
yeah you brought it up there's a there's
a shitload of games I could talk about
that that didn't that I wasn't but you
just happen to bring that one up and I'm
sure that was one of the you know
there's there's a couple of
opportunities that I family final
fantasy was one of them was like here's
a franchise that I've played that I get
to help be in and Red Faction was
another one cuz I played that first one
I was like it felt like there's a
heartbreak won in a second but I
remember playing that go I was like man
I love the story out of the world this
moves through it quickly I love the
weapons that it's giving me it moved
from like the sci-fi to horror very
quickly and then they changed everything
with Red Faction gorilla and kind of
made it a little bit less starship
trooper II and or I don't know it just
felt a little too grounded even though
you were literally destroying the [ __ ]
with a hammer like just blowing it up
but it was so cathartic but I was going
to be in Dead Space 3 I think I can
remember if they've replaced me which is
possible or they they changed the
character but I was super bummed because
I'm walking into that meeting with the
director and we just I just geeked out
over dead space I was like that moment
we were just walking to the ship and
just [ __ ] you hear I played it with the
headphones and it freaked me out it was
so good thank you
the this piece was a little I didn't
like the whole cultist thing that they
started really leaning into it like
three Dead Space 3 was another one with
the microtransactions there was one that
whole game without ever interacting with
the microtransaction it's totally
avoidable because you could farm but I
think that most of the farming because
it was very focused on weapon
customization and I liked the weapon
customisation in that game there's a lot
of things I didn't like about it hey it
wasn't scary enough lost a lot of
hemisphere somehow but there might
microtransactions could be avoided
because you could like go to certain
areas and wait for certain resources to
respawn it's not like it wasn't
aggressive I didn't feel but I that
might have been a glitch it if you got
lucky
yeah it was dead space
was pitch-black and dead space 2 was
Chronicles of Riddick because it's so
funny was gonna make a very similar
comparison but that's even better it's
like they had this magic they had this
magic sort of lightning in a bottle and
and and somehow seemed to trick is that
first one I remember that was like in
the audio world that was one of those
that everyone's like Jesus Christ
because the music was it's fine playing
it earlier this year so yeah I mean very
violent I think the reason it changed is
because EA like one of the the list of
games that I always say like if you
could make any game what would it be and
if it's an IP I always say I would take
Star Wars but make it dead space like
just making terrified oh and visceral
could have made that but yay I
interviewed someone about this maybe two
years ago and I can't tell you their
actual answer because I don't recall but
it was basically my interpretation of
that answer was we don't wanna make
horror games because we figured that
that minimizes an audience that that
takes out all of the kids who would be
playing a Star Wars game potentially is
one thing the kids hate it's watching
youtubers play horror games it's true no
one ever watches those videos like so
here's here's my pitch it's Star Wars
it's a Star Wars I love it but any also
on the perspective of a stormtrooper
okay so you know at the end of it you're
going to die you avoiding death and you
get to see Chewbacca and he's just [ __ ]
it just feral in your perspective it's
just feral beast man the Jedi really
scary but my understanding of like part
of the development of the campaign for
Battlefront 2 was that they had to make
what's her name I mean voseo the good
guy by the end of that campaign because
EA just won't let any oh it's Disney
probably won't let any of the I don't
know protagonists Heroes be bad for a
long time at all which is going to be
really restrictive creatively we did get
a question from chatty of it
like the worst person in the universe
like you want it worse for Star Wars
horror I think the way to go is it you
take c-3po s Cloud City a little side
quest of being ripped apart by the ugh
knots and you make that an entire just
horrifying
absolutely yeah exactly books
right-minded being in the chat i was
what you were gonna say about the music
and dead space awesome oh yeah before
well so it's a funny story because one
of my best composer friends I mean I
just I it sounds funny to put that kind
of label on it as if like he's in this
sort of you know like it's not really a
friend but he's a composer friend ya
know a dear friend in general but within
the composer committee is the guy that
scored the dead space trilogy jason
graves and and dead space was you know
that game that that sort of radically
elevated his his profile in the industry
and i remember i didn't know him at the
time and i read this interview where he
was like because i had heard the game
was awesome and a bad play yet and
hadn't heard the music and so but i love
that kind of thing like System Shock 2
is like one of my favorite games of all
time and this one seemed to be
scratching a similar itch just at first
glance so I was like I'm ready super
into it and I read this interview where
he was like yeah you know the music that
were that we did for the game was so
complicated and sort of violent that it
wasn't possible to do a mock-up with
MIDI and samples and stuff I had to ride
it by hand and just tell the folks you
know trust me
I'll go record the orchestra you know
just give me the money to go do that and
then I promise you'll like it and I
remember rolling my eyes and thinking
what does this guy think his music is
beyond samples and mock-ups and and I
just thought what a [ __ ] arrogant
strange thing to kind of posture about
and then I went and listened to the
music and thought how the [ __ ] could you
mock this up this is the most insane
[ __ ] I ever heard in my life and he
called him up and was like alright dude
I gotta I gotta walk you through the
little inner journey that I just had I
was sure that you were full of [ __ ] and
now like respect looks awesome rap do
that well I mean it's the funny
thing is that now there's a bunch of
libraries or you just like hit a button
and it does shrieking horrible things
where they've basically taken that kind
of music and just sampled that on its
own right so now it's extraordinarily
easy but back then you know it was
effects that the samples just can't do
all these weird things of like violins
bending the notes well scratching and
doing all these you know combinations of
stuff that they it just is not supported
by the library so hmm yeah he he
actually did convince them to just send
him off to go sort of custom sample the
orchestra and built the score from that
and it is freaking visceral I mean it's
crazy
I have a friend oh yes yeah I have a
friend who he's done some composing for
video games and some sound design but he
has done a bunch of sound design for
there's like walk through haunted houses
hmm so you know like the stuff the plays
in areas when you're being terrified
walking through a maze or whatever and a
lot of it is the stuff that you that I
feel like I hear about all the time that
I've always been like to thee do they
really do that way you know he's just
like bashing a piece of wood with
something till I'd pick up sounds and
then modifying that like that stuff so
cool it seems like you're tying it even
back to Star Wars for the perfect mo tie
one of the best talks I've ever been to
in my life was Ben Burtt the sound
designer of the Star Wars films giving
like a one-hour public lecture it's like
oh and a million others but but Star
Wars is the is the one that I mean it's
just the sheer creativity of this guy
he's every bit as important to Star Wars
as John Williams and and to me hearing
him just casually walk through all these
iconic sounds because it's crazy you
know if you if you do a movie it's kind
of like if you have one iconic line
you're like you're already ahead of 99%
of movies or games right just even just
one and if you think about sound design
being in a similar category Star Wars
has like a thousand in just the first I
mean you think about like the sound of
the lightsabers the sound of the TIE
fighters the sound of Darth Vader
breathing all of these things one after
another are sounds that you know like I
had a I had them back when we could
interact with humans I had someone over
here helping me with repairs to the
studio and he got a text message and it
was the light
Sabre beam-up sound and I was just like
dude nice know that it's like it's so
and so the thing that I love my favorite
story that I heard him tell was he was
there's this opening shot Star Destroyer
I guess POV of the camera starts to her
crawling the frame you know one of the
most iconic movie moments ever right and
so he thought okay I want this thing yes
there's no sound in space but we're not
making a realistic we're making a
fantasy film so he wants there to be
this weight this power to the Star
Destroyer so he takes a trip out to
Nevada to like a missile test site to
just record a bunch of rockets firing
and stuff figuring I'm gonna get
something beefy a lot of power raw
explosive energy but they all if you run
in your mind you realize they're all
it's a very white noisy and it's like
they don't actually sound that
terrifying unless you're looking at like
an ICBM that could kill civilization but
sonically not so much so he it was a
total bust and he goes back to his motel
and of course it's it's an American
terms like 110 degrees Fahrenheit and he
is boiling and so it's a shitty motel
Star Wars wasn't that high budget of a
film remember and so he goes and cranks
the AC and the air conditioner breaks
and starts going and so he literally
puts his microphone up and gets this low
Rumble and that's the Star Destroyer
and it was like story after story after
story like that where you just thought
man it's a it's a life lesson of just
going through life open here you know my
favorite Ben Burtt story is to tag on to
that is and this is the the running
thread and theme with him is that he
fled judo flips failure into what we
would consider success another iconic
shot they were trying to get a specific
sound for Indiana Jones and they're like
this is exactly where we need to go it's
just there's this quarry that we can
we'll be able to actually get this sound
that we need so that I guess 79 Corolla
the station wagon over and they were
trying to get up the hill to get into
the quarry and they just couldn't
they've been trying and trying and
trying is like that
where we have to get this sound and
every time they would get up to the hill
the Corolla was too weak and so it would
just slide down and then Ben Burt and
his engineer looked each other like and
they stuck a bike out by the tire and
they were as they rolled down they
recorded and that's the sound of the
boulder chasing after India's he's
leaving yeah it's a it's the same thing
it's like was he at ILM what was he
independent the Skywalker Sound general
everything that every lucas company has
done I just don't feel like the public
if accredit like like the way that they
completely I mean they basically
spearheaded digital film that that's the
thing that Lucas did you know like it
first-first have a complete digital shot
in the movie was in Star Wars like it's
he just pushed this forward so
dramatically a lot of you made may have
been up there but if you go to what was
it wasn't the ranch but what was the big
compound meaning ILM one in San
Francisco we will just gonna like name
drop that we've been Twila now just to
be absolute guarantee you know though
that I hate us
you can one-up that engine in a second
if you remind me it's it's like a museum
like like going there is is a pretty
pretty incredible thing but I went up
there because they they were working on
a prototype for what would become
battlefront but then in changing but the
way that they wanted to record it they
were like we want we want realism and so
it was me and another actor and they
have a big screening theater up there
and they put microphones on us and they
were like alright you guys run around
and so it was literally them recording
us running around going get out over
there like this is the which like you
know we can get all I could think about
it was a
Dustin Hoffman in Laurence Olivier in
Marathon Man and Dustin Hoffman would
run around as they said they said
rolling he would run around the stage
and then come in and one time Laurence
Olivier look at he goes my dear boy they
called it acting and it's like now we
want this realism sound so funny where
occasionally missing tiny bits of what
you're saying Joey
what do you mean do you maybe have a did
that happen for you guys as well as
thought of his sentence that we lost a
few words
it got garbled but I didn't feel like I
lost it lost its words were lost but not
so much substance maybe you have what is
it called like a game suppression filter
that's that's ramping up as you're
talking I'm not I'm not sure but I did
want to point out that we got comments
upon the I 11th give me a favor can you
turn off your you know that original
sound thing I was having issues on my
site I turned it off and it fixed it
maybe that's it potentially that's
something you've changed see we didn't
hear what you just said then about that
yes immediately upon saying that we have
indeed been to ILM there are two
comments in a row saying you guys suck
and I'm lucky positive we do suck we do
suck you do suck it's true like they've
got they've got did you see when you
were there the all the the oh my
goodness I forgot Jar Jar Binks in
carbonite that they've got so hey the
original and or not the original
probably but like a han Solo in
carbonite and then right next to it the
Jar Jar Binks in carbonite yeah it's
cool the only sad thing is how they're
all all the old puppets are rotting
that's the only that's the thing I found
Harper Asians all those original like
latex puppets from like ghostbusters Oh
totally no it's absolutely unavoidable
it's just kind of sad those things would
be well yeah I mean I feel like last
week's episode we spoke about permanence
a lot and the idea of things decaying
and how sad that is and it's a damn
Library of Alexandria why you did this
to me
we could keep stuff like the Dead Sea
scrolls and
declaration of independence on the
magnet carnage [ __ ] surely we can keep
the original Yoda puppet this was a
design to last but I mean you put it
like in a hyperbaric chamber or whatever
but you know this like film film stuff
is like ultra design not to last
I have Mike my girlfriend works in film
she makes puppets and Mike and yeah that
stuff like loss we've got stuff like on
the shelf from like films she's worked
on it's already degrading like it's you
can see it kind of just it's it's just
it's not designed because the the
mixture of latex and the way you make
these things cursed on for for effects
work in a movie the stuff that makes it
so pliable and perfect and safe on set
and all this stuff is exactly what makes
it absolutely not designed to be it's
not monetarily worthwhile for them to
try to make that self sustained like
they don't need to yeah it needs to look
good on camera on the day after that
weekend I would imagine it's not about
the monetary investment as it is like
it's a byproduct I think Mike it correct
me if this is a right reading what you
were just saying cuz it sounds like it's
not even about how much money you throw
at it it's just that for it to function
the way they need it to function on
camera it just you know as a secondary
by promoters can't really exactly so she
makes you make stop-motion she works a
company called like who make what do
they make they made Coraline and they
made Cuba and the two strings like she's
and she works on puppets they're it's
amazing work I'm very jealous and one of
the coolest perks of our relationship is
I get to go and visit the the sets for
these things every now and again but the
but the craziest thing that very
specific like there has been years
decades of like chemistry basically
working out how to make a hand for a
puppet because I was at the hand in the
puppet has like wires in and they posed
it between frames and all that but doing
that over and over for hours in the same
way as if you get that if you did this
to anything you had for for four hours
that's a very bad my I apologize too but
like but like it's gonna fall apart
and that's and that's the thing is they
so they've designed these hands so these
hands lost so they can shoot maybe three
seconds with a hand if
brakes in the hands of the animates in
both of my wrists from literally both
yes there was a year where I was wearing
two wrist guards and I would sometimes
have people on the internet be like is
that for fashion purposes I kept having
this recurring issue where I'd take it
off to go to the bathroom and if I was
ever drunk I would lose every single
wrist guard because I would leave it in
a bathroom somewhere and then leave and
they're like $40 a piece it was like I
would stop drinking while this is
happening I just getting drunk a lot but
anyway I did want to talk about if we
could - which is you know what the topic
that I was going to but my head went to
it I've seen some of the making of
Firewatch talks about how to even have
that main character's hands visible
doing the things that you see him doing
in a first-person perspective means that
the entire character model actually has
to break like if you see a call of duty
a character holding a gun the way that
it would actually look from your
first-person perspective if you actually
looked at the way that character model
would look based on the way that you're
holding it it would be this person just
sort of doing this is it when when if
you're making something in first-person
mmm I don't know how to phrase the
question I guess is is if you would have
to literally flip that and look at it
which I know it's not what we actually
see when we're seeing things in video
games what would it look like would it
all look completely insane and broken
yeah yeah because ultimately and this is
true like video games aren't simulations
they're they're designed to be
absolutely perfect from the very
specific position that you're from two
things one the direct consequences know
those hands are where they make sense to
be on on screen
yeah I'm but they actually the slightly
I think cooler thing anyone watching
this can go and do like go play a
first-person shooter and run into a wall
and you're gonna notice your gun never
clips through the wall because that
would look really stupid
now some games they'll do like a little
animation where the hand comes up which
is really cute and that's cool but you
can't push that through the lead or even
if you're right up closer and the reason
for that is most first-person shooters
render twice they render literally
everything else in the scene and then on
top of that they like a sticker with a
with a transparent background they then
render the gun on top
it's also like that the Ines UI the gun
is you exactly that's a really good way
of per me the guns UI and it's in so
really it's you never notice it until
the moment I point it out but now it's
going to annoy you in every first-person
shooter as you're running around you're
going to notice that that gun is
separated it's it's really visible in
like if you play like I've been playing
there to bring it eventually to a topic
remaster of Call of Duty
Henry in that first call of duty and to
be fair in every Call of Duty you spend
some time kind of like climbing through
grass behind another character your guns
never going to clip through that guy
in fact so it's gonna be this you get
these weird moments as you're going
through where he's where his foot is
closer to the camera so there than your
gun but your gun is being rendered on
top so your gun suddenly looks tiny cuz
ya next to this back Bigfoot so all of
that kind of stuff
everything when you when you see a
reloaded a guy in a game when you see a
character reloading in a game they will
from you know another character you're
you're not reloading they're reloading
they'll play one animation when you're
reloading that's again I completely
bespoke to your characters animations
yeah really
it said does that mean that multiplayer
FPS games have two models for you to
play a one for the player perspective
actually or another play yeah and
they're completely different things
completely different everything yeah
timings usually but yeah they won't be
playing playing Rainbow six like land
parties 20 years ago I I distinctly
remember when what you're saying you
could see someone's barrel like the
collisions weren't quite perfect because
you could see someone's barrel just sort
of poking through a wall as they were
looking around like they're on the other
side of a door looking for you but from
your POV you it never vanishes into the
wall and I've never really thought about
until just now it never really
technically you'll know seeing the gun
where it gets really weird is the gun
you see on the floor that you pick up is
a different gun model than one that's
gonna be in your hands after zarif and
really there's a really horrible [ __ ]
you're dropping that gun has to look
really good to you that gun that you
pick up from the ground has to exist in
the environment it has to become part of
the sticker of the play account oh no
so that's where we get into video games
graphics programming when no that's not
true because you can have two cameras
filming the same object overlaid on top
of each other so for an example that
example that would be if you were
playing a racing game when you've got
the mirror and you can see the car
behind you so they can so you can you
can have two cameras for your point in
the same screen the reason is because
things look bad from first-person
perspective if you if you hold up I
don't know like a phone to your face and
go like that
you're not gonna get a real sense of
like the dynamic interesting view of
that phone are you really get just like
everything close to your eye is really
big and everything far away small so
what they often do I think I'm I think
it's half-life 2 where someone grabbed
all of the assets the R under the hood
in half-life it might be in the first
half-life and like the revolver in
half-life is like a comedy Looney Tunes
gun where the end of it is like massive
like it's almost like a big triangle
because from first person it looks how
you would imagine a pistol would look
then you had fov on top of that and
fisheye lenses and how your eyes
actually work versus how film what it's
a whole thing there's a lot yeah it's
really really complicated really class
yeah I think it's yeah because people
don't realize how complicated it is and
that there's something that I found
really cool about I used to play games
with my ex and he like sometimes plays
games but like isn't a huge game ax and
we played the evil within together and
one thing that because I play games so
much it's really constantly I just have
kind of inherently learned level design
in a way that I'm like that box is there
because it's gonna want me to go in this
room and hide behind that box which
means he's gonna come through this way
like my brain just sort of like you know
the level like the designer absolutely
I'm like well that box just put there
for me to go behind that box and I know
that which means that a bad guy is gonna
come through that door
and I didn't quite realize how much that
means horror games are very different
experience for me versus someone who
doesn't look at games that way because
they haven't wanted the game design
what's that there's less suspense for
you is it cuz I'm like that guy's gonna
walk through the door but I also kind of
had that with even playing Resident Evil
3 well for some reason my brain goes
that's an asset that zombies actually
not going to move all of the others are
and then I'd be like wait for the
animation that means they are finally
down because I it's like when you like
oh sorry okay it's like when you it's
like when you watch an old scooby-doo
movie and you know or any kind of of
that era of hanna-barbera and you know
which doors gonna open because it's like
a slightly different color yeah it's
different yeah it's like you notice this
stuff as you I thought you were gonna
say which guy was gonna be the one where
they pull off the mask I'm sorry I'm
just gonna say we all we we all kind of
pick up this literacy we don't even know
about in everything we're consuming like
and as a creator it's often your job to
kind of play off of what you know people
don't necessarily know the three-act
structure they don't know that like
3-course of the way into a movie you've
got to have like the protagonist look
like they're going to lose people don't
know that but when it's missing it feels
really weird and broken and they know
something's up and they lose interest in
the story there's all of these kind of
these patterns that we've taught people
how to expect it's really interesting to
make them things that I found really
interesting about I took some brief
creative writing classes and university
is like my elective subjects and some
one of the things that I remember a
specific lecture being about that I've
always just remembered really distinctly
is fiction things people do have to make
sense or people will hate it but the
real world actually doesn't so you can
have someone wronged you or something in
the real world and you can spend the
rest of your life trying to figure out
the motive and it won't you won't be
like garbage but you'll still talk to
that person but in fiction if someone
doesn't have a distinct motive audiences
were rejected as terrible writing and
will be furious about it even if it
doesn't actually reflect the real world
it's like we every organizes yeah things
when we put them together and stories a
way of us doing that's a way of making
sense of the world so one of the that's
why we tell stories one of the one of
the to that end one of the coolest
projects I've ever been able to be a
part of was this show called this gaming
life with this trio of comedian
songwriters called tripod hey it's
really our native
you form Australian I thought both of
you were British so I I this show was
the the other origins of it was the
Melbourne Symphony commissioning the
three of them to basically write songs
about being nerdy gamers that I would
then transform into this kind of
over-the-top orchestral presentation and
so it's kind of a musical it's kind of
we jokingly called in an orchestra
cabaret show and played this to me once
right I feel like I signed your studio
once and you played me some songs from
this I had to have because it's
absolutely it was very much my times
it's just so great and there's such
brilliant lyricists and songwriters and
and we had so much fun working on this
thing and and geniuses like certified
geniuses yeah very really really cool
abandom they so one of the songs to the
point that you're making like the whole
show it's it's loosely narrative around
the idea of the three of them working
out how for the 20 years they've been
the band tripod they've always had
gaming going on in the background of
that and it at certain points it's not
even been the background they used to
joke that their show their live shows
was a warm-up to the halo matches that
they would be playing immediately
afterward and so like that it's a
recurring theme through the show that
they all have kind of different games
that they're into and yon one of the
guys there's a whole bit about how he
only plays gun games and so as part of
because I'm conducting the orchestra
they do this whole thing about how he
absolutely will not play journey under
any circumstances should people in it
and they're like you're a psycho and
it's really funny so there's a there's a
bit where the show actually gets a
little bit real where there's a song
this is brilliant very tripod thing to
call it the song is called safety in
numbers and the idea of it is the reason
we play games is because the real world
doesn't make sense but in a game you
know that some programmer and some
engineer and some artists they
manufactured a world so that when things
happen they're designed to happen and so
at its scariest you have this kind of
cradling hands keeping you sort of on a
path and like an ATV
tells this whole story about how hmm how
he had like this road rage incident and
it really shook him up and there was
just no way to kind of make sense of it
and it was really kind of scary for a
moment and then he like boots up world
of warcraft any figures nothing can
possibly be that scary in this
environment it's sort of the beauty of
there being safety in in numbers and I
it's it's absolutely one of my favorite
bits in the end I mean so how did in LA
the other night and every time that
there's an earthquake here that was
pretty brutal actually anytime there's
an earthquake here I have this pause
where I'm like is this gonna go away off
to three seconds or is this the one my
brain is always like what's gonna happen
at what point do I need to run under a
table and then they leave and I'm like
okay is it gonna be an off to shock when
it's the next one and I just have this
it doesn't make me anxious so scared I
just have this very much like awareness
of like what does this mean if there was
an earthquake in a video game I would be
like accident something major is going
to happen this is going to you a full
shadow in something and I guess he's
regressing yeah like a nother wouldn't
happen randomly yeah generally that's
what Chekhov's gun is a thing right like
if we're trains to expect if we see
something in fiction in a game in a
movie if we if something is held up to a
camera and goes this is important we
assume it's important whereas they say
in real life it's just many games that
don't do that that the only one that's
really distinctly coming to mind and of
course there are other games like it for
me would be layers of fear which is
intentionally unsettling and that things
happen for no reason to move for no
reason even when there's no threat it
just makes it extremely uncomfortable to
play all the time because just weird
[ __ ] happens and you turn around and the
hallways different but that's not
necessarily anything attacking you
they just keep changing things all the
time and I think that that that being in
a video game where you are used to
having some kind of control or to
readily having expectations that are
often fulfilled
it's very jarring to play something like
layers of fear where absolutely none of
your expectations mean anything on the
next room could be completely different
to the last room and you can look like
you're in a different plane I really
like those games because of that I also
feel
one of the reasons why there's a there's
a dissonance between that like you said
if something happens to real life we
don't know necessarily what that means
but if we're watching and reviewing it
it's because we are our own editors
we're on our directors and editors right
so we are our experiences and our
viewpoint is going that's important
that's not important constantly which is
the same why you can be in a very loud
room and all of a sudden you hear your
name and that perks up because your
brain is running this Auto filter
constantly of like this is not important
this is not important that is important
life would probably be unlivable if we
are brain didn't do that it'd be like
Stevens overload 24/7 sure watching
something someone is doing that for us
and so we must adapt to that language
and they must be a lot of times and this
is one of the problems I think a lot of
game designers have is that they go we
have to make sure that the player
understands this is important and they
go too far to that and as a post going
trust that they're with you and if we've
told our story well they're tracking
that that's important and we don't have
to constantly constantly reiterate that
that's important I really wanted to talk
about Final Fantasy but I feel like
we're now half an hour into this topic
that is also very interesting and I did
get a question from chat earlier that i
haff know the answer to but I feel like
I'll let you speak to more Mike is when
games are written and a plot is written
how how does that start and how closely
does that work with design because from
my understanding a lot of games writing
depends on the game but a lot of the
time you can write something and have
anyone else in the room be like well
that doesn't work with the way that
we've designed this level and then you
have to so you write a script that area
is made maybe they couldn't do what was
scripted and then you have to rewrite
the thing based on what how the game
plays so it's like this constant like
piece of and your writing gets thrown
out because they're like we can't make
that it's not gonna work they don't just
not everything is just written with a
script in mind it is also like you can
literally just throw out parts of the
script and then have to make it adapt
based on the way the game is made is my
understanding of how it works yeah but
like in various different like degrees
and configurations like
honestly like what you just described is
like obviously in most cases the best
case scenario right and like there's a
really I don't to be a jerk I feel like
it's my job at once an episode to be
judgmental but generally the stories
that come out of a game studio you can
definitely tell which games videos are
run by writers or by people who put
story first like there's definitely a
correlation between games you think have
great stories or they are well received
their stories and and whether the people
who are good at telling stories are in
charge because because yet basically in
all in all game development it's always
a collaboration between a bunch of
different departments doing different
things from the QA department and the
artists to the designers to the coders
to everything marketing has a say and
rightly so in my opinion all the time um
there's a million different people
trying to pull their stuff together and
and yeah you're basically dancing to the
tune someone else is playing at all
times
and that's fine but it can yeah you can
end up with if one to continue my very
labored metaphor in a room with someone
who is a professional composer so I'm
gonna trip myself up here but if one
section of the orchestra is too loud
thank you so it's always it's always
that back and forth and yes generally
like the way we do stories is I'll often
actually and this is quite rare ology
often write a story before we even kind
of started Lee not necessarily like a
script because writing Jung sit down and
go like you know scene one this happens
scenes you don't write things out in a
very linear way often you go very
structural with it most most writers
start with like they'll work out their
beets they'll work out their structure
of the story narrative um then we're
doing at the moment we're doing a radio
show plug that's that's all stuff that
was all structured beforehand in
spreadsheets and then we've got I've
gone through and I've kind of written my
spreadsheet like tells me okay you've
got 250 words of the the narrator here
and it has to convey this boost piece of
information because we really need its
to three scenes from now so you do a lot
of that planning work if that's done and
that's respected then you can build
levels off of it you can work out what
your how everything works you can make
tweaks back into that structure where it
goes wrong is
when the writing has been has progressed
to a stage where you've written dialogue
when you've kind of really worked out
what the scenes are and then something
has to change because of that later
stage you're you're one step removed
from the planning process it's the
difference between sitting with someone
and working out the route you're gonna
take the day before versus being in the
car and trying to course-correct as
you're going that's the you know it's I
kind of you can you can make it's harder
to make those changes later and good
game studios understand that and kind of
there's a lot more back and forth with
munication bad game studios and I've had
this happen to writer friends literally
they'll be like you we've got 11
locations 11 levels in our game here's
the story beats laid out here's where
the cutscenes will be this is what story
is oh no we can't do level 9 anymore
because that's expensive we've got to
cut corners they take that level out
they never go back to the writers and
now just something's missing and then
every single review of that game says
it's a badly written game this thing
never paid off and the writers would be
the ones who get the criticism even
though it doesn't necessarily happen
that way exactly that's a logistical
problem right but likewise you also can
have situations I don't want to pretend
right as a perfect like writers will
write bad stories and then game
designers are we trying to fix them the
other thing that's really interesting
and I think often kind of can cause it's
more kind of human level issues is that
both game design and writing are such
fuzzy jobs and such jobs that everyone
rightly has like an opinion about what
those jobs are and what and maybe thinks
they can do those jobs in a lot of cases
you have it's the better two jobs which
the most different kind of people in the
game so you're going to have opinions
and throwing ideas and then wanting to
change things and one to tweak things no
one's debating with the programmer about
how they should optimize for performance
right we leave that to the programmers
but in terms of like story notes and
design that can be much more of a fluid
organic thing in the company which again
if you manage it well can be an awesome
thing where a lot of cool ideas come
through if you manage it badly it can
end up in a situation where someone who
have no involvement in the writing
process decides this character should
have this cool quick view I've literally
seen it where like whether it's like a
meme about like you know it means going
around the internet everyone's
everyone's doing it on so everyone's
doing this and then a producer will say
oh we have to have a scene and litters
on project with someone when they add
Gangnam style they're like we need
Gangnam style it's really hot right now
we're like the games are coming out for
a couple years no one comes in
I always interesting it's so funny you
say that because it always makes me
think of the difference between Family
Guy and South Park where I've seen it
where like the Family Guy episode
because it has like a 10 month
production pipeline
it will have some 10 month old pop
culture reference for that reason but
because South Martin they turn them
around in six days that's why they're so
so good right on the news but it's
interesting how Family Guy can be so
hilarious but the moment at least back
in the day and and they they would have
these incisive bits but then it would
feel like oh I forgot about that and it
really was only maybe half a year
earlier in games yeah it's even more
extreme that's yeah why wasn't there
Gangnam style and hex I feel he's now
feel screwed he only wouldn't do it just
quick shout out to robot ninja shock who
just donated $50 which is technically
two weeks of hosting for this show it
cost me about 50 bucks 100 bucks a month
to host the show so thank you [ __ ] that
might just donate a $10 as well yeah is
it weird you sound fine when it picks
you up it's that it kind of like filters
you out at the start so it's like it's
assuming yes like you to you until you
stop it is the one
yeah gated but that's that's some that's
some zoomy stuff I want to turn that off
Jesus I just want to kind of go off on
robot ninja shark real quick that dude
is incredible he is absolutely a
philosopher that's of great
conversations and he he says have been a
prolific mentioned Tim last episode and
I know that because I had this moment
where I looked and I saw it and when I
was editing it because I remember the
moment where I thought really hard about
what a robot ninja shark would look like
and I have you can see it very
distinctly on camera where I'm like for
like a good five seconds trying to
figure out what a robot ninja shock if
you if you were a robot a ninja and a
shot you're gonna have an interesting
world you just
based on that right big three good socks
I'm sure plex
logistically complex and brave enough to
share something on Twitter where he just
he talked about his experience with his
wife the the really kind of let him kind
of say that but he went through like a
real big physical medical ordeal and he
said it dawned on him that what he was
experiencing was the human condition and
that just resonated so well with me so
everybody right now who's kind of in
this still trying to find the new normal
and still trying to find equilibrium and
the balance of this the thing that he
said that gave him comfort and gives me
comfort too is that this is the human
experience we're experienced in the
human condition which means this has
been experienced by generations before
us so when even in that were not alone I
was like dang dude that's yeah yeah I
think you did talk about that maybe a
couple of episodes ago that clearly very
much stuck with you man it's good to see
that tweet yeah it's on as whatever
robot ninja don't even know what you're
I guess you robot ninja shark I don't
know Michael have a question for you
like everybody does Craig Mazin who is
the showrunner for Chernobyl and also
most recently got he's gonna be doing
the The Last of Us show for HBO he has
the podcast called script notes plug and
that he talked about structure is a well
I was trying to look through my notes to
find it because I wrote it down hit me
so far is its structure is a bi-product
structure is a symptom it's not you you
don't go okay here's my structure you
end up writing your story and out of
that you have it is structured because
you did it well do you agree with that
notion because I'm not pushing against
it what you said but you said you have
to kind of start from this if there's
writers that are watching this like
Blake Snyder has his whole thing is like
here's he kind of did a drive-thru
version of Joseph Campbell and and and
said here's basically what yeah
my jzuk campbell's in the next room but
I've probably got save the copy here
save the cat if you're a writer is a
great book for you to read to understand
what a lot of writers in this industry
will reference what I would I would
definitely say Robert McKee is is for
writing in films much better resource
it's it's Blake Snyder's this thick
Robert McKee is this thick it's like 750
pages it's a tome but Blake Snyder says
on this page you should have this moment
on this page you should have moment and
then is your structure and I feel like
Craig Mazin just kind of pushed away for
those like no you don't have a structure
you write your story and you find out
after the fact that it's structured
there it is
the magic magic shelf delivers again my
cue is in the next stream unfortunately
so I can't do the double feature but
yeah so so to answer your question
that's awesome to answer your question
the dude who wrote Chernobyl is a better
writer than me that's the short version
of the so I genuinely like I think
probably he's yeah probably he's just
like either exceptionally gifted or
probably more likely just extremely more
experienced than me for me I need a road
map I need I need to put that structure
often I'll change the structure I'll
realize all I need to do something
different but know like if someone's
like I still consider myself like a
beginner with this stuff I write jokes
long enough that kind of disguises the
problems of my storytelling and I think
you know for me I need the structure I
and also a Metroid we've chatted about
this kind of privately like it's the way
I approach things is always a very
design-led thing like I I need to sit
down and I need to make a plan I need to
structure staff I need to like I said
like literally plug north star rising
podcasts Austin Troy there you go Cohen
listen to that it's it's quite good I
think second episode of Troy's after the
first episode was this week I see yeah
um but the but with that like literally
I'm working out the spreadsheet and I'm
working okay for 250 words I need to
introduce this new characters gonna run
round and do their thing and be
introduced that's what I need if I was a
better writer
maybe you know a few years from now
maybe I'll be able to kind of comment
the other direction I think you do end
up with stuff that's more formulaic if
you take that approach for sure and I
think I'd probably be my biggest
criticism of my work is that it
definitely follows a three-act structure
religiously all I can say to that is the
one time I tried not to which was Thomas
was alone
Thomas was lonely as a perfect three act
structure except for the last act where
I was like you know what I'm gonna do my
own thing and mess up every single
review go find me a review of Thomas was
alone that doesn't say Thomas was alone
as last act sucks every single review is
like wow the storytelling so good for
the first two acts and then what the
hell was the own thing about the idea of
good storytelling has become what we
expect from a three act structure
because we've always had three acts
structures does literacy yeah because we
expect a three act structure so if it
doesn't have one we like disappointing
ending
it's unsatisfying you don't think that's
an that's a new invention I mean I don't
think I don't think Snyder did that well
if you look back like Beowulf is that
like it says there's like there is a we
it's what it's what you were saying and
it's altum Utley comes down to causality
it's person once a thing person tries to
get a thing person gets the thing or
they get what they really need it all
along that's just that's just a
satisfying causality thing well over
time we've added wrinkles to that we've
been my god well they want to be strong
but actually they need to realize that
the true strength was in their heart all
along and you know that kept us going
through the 80s you know there's these
kind of things improve but ultimately is
about causality and about putting
meaning into life it's not a sequence of
things that happens it's got to be more
than that because that's what our brains
want to deciphering the world and they
enjoy stories because they're fast food
they just deliver us an experience and
they and they give us a satisfying
anything it means something when the
Avengers pull it off in the end you feel
good because someone laid that out for
you to feel good whereas if you enter
into the real world and had like an
experience and met a new person you'd
have to put work into that to get
something out of it emotionally yeah
it's fun it's why we tell stories I just
don't say another quick thank you to
pagan place for just donating fifty five
pounds thank you so much we really
appreciate it
it's very cool the we call it jazz right
like that that was a name that was given
to something it's it's three act
structure came about because that was
the story that men surface right it's
not necessarily that okay yeah sit down
and write okay here's our straight three
act structure it was like you said
person what's that saying
person needs to get a thing person gets
the thing it was talk about people that
[ __ ] the bed on like the the last half
like look at Stephen King that's his
fate like he can build a world and he
could create characters his thing is
characters tension and dialogue that's
what he does not do story very well at
all bless you yes
I just watched Outsiders and it's like
as soon as I knew that it was gonna be a
Stephen King thing is like oh it's gonna
be should be at the end with the
exception of Shasha and Green Mile it's
it's like you know it's gonna [ __ ] the
bed at the end read Stephen or something
else to be read Stephen King's book
alright same Troy do you find that
really interesting that is really
interesting it's fascinating I disagree
with 90% of their I do not like the way
I've been its part I mean who the [ __ ]
Stephen King right like it's definitely
that thing of like what is he again if
that writes to me was he written but
like definitely like when I read it cuz
he writes things he doesn't do any
structure he'll he'll he just writes a
story and so he thinks he's an ending
life and personally in his work similar
to Troy like he doesn't seem great so
endings to me and I think Paul guys
because he's not said something about
that it chapter two I believe where it's
it's a pawn about how bad he is it
endings that's definitely an ongoing
thing the other thing that I find
fascinating about Stephen King and I may
have said this before is that everything
he's ever written takes place within the
Dark Tower universe yeah I like that no
that's that's that being serene about
Mary it's all of it all of it takes
place within the same universe which is
why it allows that fiction to be to be a
thing I think that's super cool the to
the point of
you know to the extent that we need
these expectations and this and that and
the rest I I think the problem with
holding Joseph Campbell up as like the
God Paragon yeah exactly
is that his he was not doing this what
you're describing about Stephen King
saying here's how to write a story his
his title was comparative mythologist he
was going and saying I'm just a little
instruction yeah that's and that's the
point I was making we gave it the label
jazz after it had kind of formed enough
tropes or consistent gestures and and
whatnot that we could kind of group
things together meaningfully and they
weren't just sort of like really
adventurous versions of folk songs or
whatever it was like okay that these
things have kind of clustered enough
away from the rest that we can give it a
new label and and it's the same with
I've been reading about this kind of
thing a lot lately and every genre has
that kind of origins story you know
where it's like people were just sort of
in one place and we're continuously
pushing and and defying all those
formulas and to me that's that's that's
always the most exciting but I think
that's where you end up in this
challenge where you know the four of us
make stuff so we are naturally inclined
to go for the things that subvert those
formulas and we enjoy those things
because we're so literate in those
formulas that like for me this is a very
nerdy example I guess but like x-men so
cool up to this point where yes it's
true Francis is a people that's true
yeah I'm not gonna try to compete so I
the composer the 19th century composer
Brahms he wrote four symphonies and one
two and four are all super popular and
three is by far the least popular and
it's by far my oh there you go oh well I
finally finally the beauty as it needs
to be that's a his third symphony is my
ticket okay so the super matter even
lucky wait up till now it's great I've
actually never seen that before
try back oh come on and tell the Brahms
sorry and over
don't need to look at the chart to know
that negative want the glasses back on
the thing that's so annoying is that the
reason the third one is the least
popular is the reason why I love it the
most is if you think of like the classic
generic classical music symphony it ends
with the big you know Paw Paw Paw Paw
Paw bum bum bum bum Bubba and he doesn't
do that he there's a there's a great
book called death set to music that
references this piece as like it's it's
similar to the act of dying it basically
just fades away into oblivion and it's
so haunting and so beautiful but
audiences are like but I need my bubble
butt and so the mourners just don't
program it and I'm like it's the same
you need your big boss fight battle
imagine if the game made it your boss
fight was halfway through and the whole
rest of the game was like a descent into
something quiet it's like all four of us
probably go ooh I want to play I go oh
yes like then you look at the Metacritic
and then you look at steam spy and all
the rest and it's like the art is
knowing where you can write the art is
knowing that's and the Thomas was alone
example from earlier like that's an
example of me being too naive and
breaking a rule without really
understanding or being good enough to
break it successfully
whereas like definitely like since then
I think I feel like we all have done
this like where we are actively like
we're gonna do the obvious thing but
then we're gonna tweak that we're gonna
change that back I remember like yeah we
John wake Austin like some of your music
stuff was just I remember us having lots
of conversations about like how how far
do we want to push away from what's been
established around I think I think as
long as you those along as a mediated
kind of thought through process that can
be really cool but it's you're playing
with fire at that point right I
something that I feel like a
through-line for all for people that are
on this is exactly what Austin said
which is all four of us we could do the
obvious thing we could do the structure
there's Mike there's a story that you
know you could tell it this way but you
choose or there's a game that you know
you can make this way but you choose to
do something differently look at John
wick on its face on paper that is a
shooter that's what that game should be
and uses Joseph's
agree with you about your style eyes you
know basically turn-based strategy game
austin going when you were at USC right
USC yeah depending on how the story goes
yes maybe but you when you're when you
were in college people say okay if you
listen to an orchestra let's write a
piece we're all gonna share this thing's
you know let's do a chamber orchestra
for four horns and you're like now i
wanna give me give me 16 Piccolo's like
what's the weirdest version of this that
i can write and alana you've written
stories and reviews that have been like
i'm gonna go against the grain because
this is my perspective and me i i hate
doing the obvious take i always love to
go what's the what's the weirdest
version of this line that i can do and
it's about finding those people and
those partners that allow you to do that
as opposed to just kind of going with
people that are like just give me let's
I feel like life is too short to play it
safe I tell you how easy that is
journalist to like find outlets a little
be like what if you didn't do that and I
always want to say to IGN's credit
because most people would not cut it IGN
for it I could write whatever I wanted
there was never any point where I was
writing a feature at IGN that was
extremely critical of a publisher that
anyone ever said anything other than
great job keep doing what you're doing
whereas people would think that they
would cut that stuff off literally never
happened it's so good about letting
journalists write literally would have
thought they weren't I could write about
depression I could I could write about
butts in video games one time I ranked
the amiibo in order of attractiveness
but we never published it because it was
super weird they were still like right I
think I'm gonna publish that one but you
wrote it and we appreciate that you
wrote it probably have it on Google
Drive probably eat go ahead and publish
that [ __ ] one time that we went back to
potentially publishing it
there was so many more amiibo and that
thing already took so long just not this
is a very grueling process and I don't
know if I want to do it now they
technically on
Rights which is related to something
that I wanted to ask today I have this
thing in my industry unintentional segue
that well anywhere I've ever written
anything for any time to ever use me on
camera they now own all of that right so
like even at inside gaming if I'm
writing a news story and I reference
something in IGN that I wrote I have to
credit from IGN I can't say I wrote this
this is an article I wrote a bit back so
I'm sourcing myself I can't do that I
have to source IGN because even though I
wrote the words I don't own the word
stay on my likeness for all the time
that I was there they go in every image
of me they can do whatever they want
with anything that they have of me and I
feel like I've seen and I never want to
make this show respond to a hot take so
I don't want to put you on the spot here
Austin but I feel like there's been this
controversy this week about Mick Gordon
and doom and a lot of it's blown up so
I'm not even gonna get into it too much
but one thing that really stood out to
me is doom eternal it seems that he
didn't mix or master all of the tracks
he did some of them someone else did the
others and I feel like the community is
very angry about that about the idea
that he didn't get to master all of the
music that he wrote but my thought was
immediately like but he doesn't own that
music so they can do whatever they want
with it would I be right to deceiving
that like if he's working for them
couldn't they can kind of they can
market if they want
I mean it's there's a contract law to a
sauce - yeah let's do it let's do that
[Laughter]
the long and short of it is that there's
a there's a variety of types of
contracts that composers asked to sign
but generally speaking on a triple-a
title like that a work-for-hire
agreement is going to be the default
position which basically is you are
correct we own this music and and you
know we may in turn license back to you
some ancillary rights like it's pretty
common that they say we own it
completely outright but we will kind of
after after receiving it will give you
rotis on like soundtrack album sales and
things like that even though technically
if
you know once that ownership right has
been assigned they don't have to do that
but it's just part of the negotiation
process and it's relatively standard to
just assume that there will be
soundtrack album royalties but but
there's plenty of examples of composers
that have albums that do crazy
gangbusters and never saw a penny for it
and so it's all it all comes down to
kind of what your what trade-offs are
willing to make like is the credit worth
more than there's long term dollars or
short term dollars and I'm not of the
mind that that any contract type is sort
of by default predatory but that's a
tangent and as much as we love those and
will answer your question
so yes Mick I don't know yeah you know
he and I know each other a little bit I
haven't talked to him about I haven't
talked to him in a little while and I
saw this story and a lot of my composer
friends were sharing it the instant that
it went live and I I kind of you know
have been waiting for the dust to settle
with just all the frenzy around it to
see what's the real story because I saw
like there's anything definitive at all
that husband said he tweeted one thing
about it which is responding to somebody
who was initially got this story going
where they were comparing the waveforms
of the soundtrack album releases which
that's a whole other thing to unpack is
that the assets in game are not
necessarily and in fact almost certainly
are different from what would be on an
album so just setting that whole thing
aside for a second they were just
showing that the doom eternal masters
were like this solid block just
compressed to all hell which means that
you lose all nuance and all the color
which if you know mixed music is it's
loaded with nuance in color so it was
like somebody noticed hey this doesn't
sound as good as the last one then
that's that's weird and they did a
little bit of audio analysis and
observed why and he just had one little
tweet responding to their thread saying
that's why we like the site a huge thing
yeah I didn't I didn't actually mix
those and of course then a lot of people
got all angry and the bottom line is
most developer for example I've never
been in this position every developer
and publisher I've worked with even
where I've given them absolute total
control over everything like like
Ubisoft on Assassin's Creed syndicate
that is absolutely the same kind of
contract they have the right
do anything they want but they also
realize would say they're paying for it
yeah absolutely I didn't feel like like
I can understand having someone take
your work and make it lower quality
sucks like that Tris [ __ ] sucks but
my head immediately just went well isn't
that don't they also pay for the right
to be able to compress that if they want
dude they do pay for the right but in my
experience and and I brought up Ubisoft
as a to highlight this almost and I'm
amazed that it wouldn't be the case in
something like this with it in Bethesda
and whoever and I really I don't know
what happened there there's a lot of
really good people there so it's hard to
guess and I don't I don't want to
speculate but setting that aside in my
experience these folks part of why they
hire you and why they pay for that right
to do whatever they want is because they
appreciate what you do and I've never
had somebody take something away from me
and say we're gonna mix this ourselves
and we're going to do this because
they're like at that point they're
paying for a thing they're not getting
the full value from that it's a strange
self-defeating proposition from their
from their point to do that it would be
like you hire Troy and then you line
read through every single thing and then
you chop it up afterward and then you
like pitch it down an octave and you do
all this it's like at some point you've
lost the thing that you paid for it and
even though you're exercising something
totally within your right it's still
kind of like but why why would you you
could have you could have had a much
cheaper much more generic thing if
you're how to do all that stuff
do it anyway in the end in Austin
there's something that you say that I
love and I want to make sure I don't
miss caught you you say I don't sell
what is your quarter I don't sell these
solution I sell the process by which we
will get there is that right yeah I mean
when I'm talking to new developer I tend
to try to explain to them that my
product in my opinion ideally my product
is not the music it's the collaboration
that gets us because I love working with
developers and and people to bounce
ideas back and forth and get somewhere
that I couldn't get on my own mm-hmm
this oh sorry
don't I'm just gonna say like a little
nuance for my the other side of that
contract essentially for my the
developers side it's actually really
hard to
music it's like one of the few things so
most most of the time when I hire
someone's work on one of our games by
definition like I pay an amount of money
they give me exclusive and complete
rights to their work writing like an
artist makes a model for the game and
then that goes into the game and we use
it and that's that's a very simple
standard trade I think most people can
understand how I would work right with
music because of like the long history
of music rights and how complicated all
that is we actually made a decision as a
studio years ago not to ever try and
assert rights to music because it was
just so contractual complex and
expensive so much hassle so like we
don't own any of our soundtracks like
all of our music we have license to them
we have good relationships with our
collaborators I can't remember the John
wick deal because it was those
publishers so that's not going to
Allison but literally everything else
yeah so everything else like Thomas was
alone David house and you did the music
for that he owns that soundtrack he can
sell that soundtrack if that soundtracks
even been used I've seen like
commercials on TV that used Thomas was
alone music as like backing music and
it's like fair play man if you can get
some value out of that good on you
that's great and it's but but we as a
studio and this is because we're an
indie studio as well we just decided
years ago like we're just not going to
jump into this we get licensing for
music and you can see that like down the
sack who's done our last couple circular
games again owns his albums he can do
whatever he wants with because it's
really hard and so I wonder if there's
some new ones to this situation that's
part of that obviously I realized
they're bigger companies so yeah I feel
like the Internet is very very
black-and-white about this particular
one I think people yeah people think IP
and the purchasing of licenses and work
and intellectual property is much
simpler than it actually is like it's
very complex and with music massively
more so than anything else
I know Troy you're about to say
something I just well I just got you
like an open browser tab I'll be two
units I just I just
a comment on that very last point of
mike's because part of the reason why
things are so much more complicated is
because music is uniquely empowered to
exist outside of the thing well you know
I'm gonna go to a concert of 3d models
that the artists made I'm finished with
Duma Tunnel but I want that soundtrack
on Spotify so bad
unrelated to that thing exactly or a
live show or whatever like you said
there could even be license
opportunities for music two whole other
so it's just worth mentioning that part
of the reason why it's so nominalist
with music is because it's it's
different from almost every other facet
of what goes into a game and how
transportable it is now I'm quiet
I'm joking thank you does access the
donating seriously we've had I don't
know this would be so it costs to to
publish this show right so this stream
is just paid for the last month of
publishing so thank you all for doing
Thank You Troy go ahead you just for
blue light because I've been staring at
screens a lot and so this is I just got
some these are like nothing yeah I think
to push against that a little bit Austin
I think that there's a huge there is
there is a difference between a music is
anomalous and able to do that but you're
not why you may not go to a concert for
those 3d models there's huge opportunity
for people to merchandise and take a
listing asset and go give it to somebody
else so I understand the use glyphs it
exclusivity and the same right it's a
little bit more from the performance
there's not much I could do with like my
performance and take that outside of and
put it somewhere else but I like what I
hear from you is that you made a
philosophical choice as a studio to
understand that you're in the games
business you're not in the music
business that you you have to be focused
on this and you like you said you do
have the ability and the agility as an
independent studio to be able to just do
that whereas most studios are going how
can we grow and now get into film and TV
and music and games and we're gonna get
this this little arm and by and large if
you look at the big big
publishers with the exception of like I
mean Activision doesn't really get into
the whole TV and film route but like
Warner Brothers has you know they're
there they're a huge conglomerate Sony
has a big glommer they do consumer
electronics to film to TV to music Sony
is one of the biggest music distributors
in the world so I understand them going
no no no we're gonna pay for that and we
own that because we haven't in order to
do that I just really applaud you cuz
I'll never forget this was maybe 15
years ago 15 or 20 years maybe 15 years
ago Don Henley was quoted by saying well
son of a [ __ ] I finally own Hotel
California because the the publishing
deal had expired and there's a
difference between and I understand like
look if if I'm footing the bill for
everything I want to be able to I took
the risk yes you have the product but I
took the risk of putting that thing to
market so I'm assuming all the risk if
the worst risk that the artist assumes
is that they that the art is bad or is
not received well I paid for it to be
bad I understand if I'm a producer me
paying for something I'm going to be
first money in first money out but I do
believe in the artist being able to
profit off of that however they can
because if you're fortunate enough to
write a song a book make a game a script
whatever it is if you could do one of
those in your life that's incredible to
be able to make that your vocation to to
monetize your passions and to turn your
recreation into a vocation that's that's
the ultimate goal for everybody Troy so
Troy as a voice actor in your field
people literally own your voice and you
will often be I think I tweeted yes I
called you Joel from the Last of Us but
you could also do it whoever else a
million characters Sam whatever Pete
they own your voice I feel like that in
the first place is weird but but my
actual question was going to be if you
go to a convention
what's the legality behind you
advertising yourself Oh being advertised
as Joel from The Last of Us you are not
a Sony employee you don't work for
Naughty Dog but you are you still very
much publicly allowed to be that person
or are there restrictions on that no
there's never been the only thing that's
been really weird and I'm I'm very
cautious about this it's like if I go to
a convention the the agreement that we
have with that convention is that I I
will have an appearance there for the
agreement of some sum of money and the
Khan makes their money back on investing
in me being there by the the currency
exchange of autographs or whatever for
that what I'm very cautious about is
that if I use it if they have pictures
of that character I don't own the rights
of that picture it sell that picture
they can't sell that picture because
that's them selling Sony property Warner
Brothers property Activision's property
or whatever for their own gain and I'm
not going to be complicit in that if
it's a picture of me I mean you could
pay my wife for the picture that she
took or whatever but it's it's that's
not a thing it's it's the interaction
with me that I guess is the is the
product at that point but no because
it's a because it's it's a public
knowledge thing it's like well yeah I
played Sam Drake in uncharted 4 and I
could say hey that's the guy from Sandra
gonna charter for it there's no
ownership to that that's that's just a
fact right well that's probably if it's
anything like music contracts it's
probably spelled out and we're and we're
getting a bit into the weeds here but
there's a difference between the
intellectual property as this abstract
concept of like the character of Booker
versus the the in music would be like
the master recording which is that
specific take that you did which is the
thing that's now in the game like they
don't actually own your voice they own
that performance of your voice and I
mean you so only own they only own if
about use as well so like in a couple of
my things now I can't take those
recordings of Troy and like
the princess layer him into something
else interesting Baker in this game you
want to I think my industry might be the
most restrictive based on this
conversation and that like when I worked
for IGN for example I was not allowed to
talk about video games on YouTube I
wasn't allowed to talk about movies I
wasn't allowed to talk about anything
entertainment related because they owned
every thought I had about those things I
wasn't allowed to scream non-compete
clause pretty much even if they hired me
in part because I had a YouTube channel
with 80,000 subscribers where I only
spoke about video games they completely
stopped me from being able to do that
and then I have an interesting thing
with my contract at roosterteeth where
this would never be enforced they would
never do it but I believe it's written
somewhere I can't tell you the exact
phrasing that if you advertise a
personal project on a roosterteeth
program they then on it so if I were to
be like go check out play watch listen
on dude suit which is the fun house
podcast they would they would be like
the minute you advertise it on our stuff
we own it which again dentistry is never
anything to that [ __ ] the games
industry there is I'm not gonna say who
because I would get in a lot of trouble
but there is a publisher so NDA's
existing people generally no one NDA is
you sign a contract and keep each other
secrets in a question aside there is a
publisher who in their NDA on page 5
owns the rights any game you pitch them
so I can't I've literally cancelled
because obviously I read NDA's I've
literally gone to a meeting been handed
that NDA
read it got up left not come back you
know there is there people who do that
and that's and that stuff goes on games
as well yeah I had I had a in a similar
in a similar manner to that I I will not
say which project it is even though even
though I don't think it will ever come
up in the same spirit a lot of like I
don't think this would ever be enforced
but so funny enough I was working on a
game once where it was absolutely a full
work for hire they own they own the
master recording which means the actual
audio files but they also own the
intellectual property which means that
if I did a cover arrangement and
you know made it if I did a new version
of that with those notes even if it's
not in the game they I'm technically a
cover artist now and would have to
license it through those means even
though I wrote it originally so I was
working on a game once where a dear
friend lost his wife while I was working
on the project and there was a melody
that I had snuck in that I had written
with him that she had come down the
aisle to at their wedding years before
and so as a little Easter egg in this
game that I was working on I put the
melody for that like so that we could
record it in the score and I can have
this like sort of special version of
this piece and it's actually in the game
you can find it's like a little monument
to this friend of Mines wife she was a
dear friend of mine too there's a little
hidden monument to her in one of these
games that I worked on but I'm never
saying him side note technically now
this music is owned by this this company
because they have no idea that it was
pre-existing and technically I'm
probably not allowed to even be doing
this but it's not like we copy the piece
was copy written even those I mean it's
just like a little personal thing but it
was one of those that I said this will
never come back to bite us in the ass
but I'm just gonna make you aware of
course I was telling him after it was
too late like my jeans closest would
have even I think prevented me from even
tweeting about video games but they were
like yeah but they never stopped me from
they encouraged it they retweeted me you
know but like I think some of that stuff
is just written by a lawyer who's so
careful about anti compete causes that
doesn't actually represent the editorial
team which is the same case for a lot of
these things like a lot of them
outsourced contract lawyers that just
don't even necessarily know sometimes
sometimes there's like weird legal
things as well like we definitely like I
definitely had to have these
conversations with lawyers like with
because we have employees right and if
your employer allowed you to do those
things and then that turned out that
what you were making on the side was
something like offensive law for illegal
they would in theory then be liable to
some extent so sometimes it's just
by covering in that way it sounds like
way you're describing is like way beyond
what you have to do oh yeah I've worked
on India's before where I remember
working on a project once where I won't
say what it is just it's live as well
guys there's no safety net of calling
Alana an hour from now and going hey you
know that bit can we just go ahead and
see which has 100% happened right for I
think all of us have made something of
some yeah we've all we've all said
something as a bit naughty but no in
this case it was a project where it was
an indie project where the developers
had all met while working for a triple-a
publisher and they started brainstorming
this idea for their game while they were
still employees and then they decided to
do a Kickstarter for it and so they quit
their jobs they did the Kickstarter went
really well and they were able to make
their game and I was and I was able to
work with them and I was talking with
them and it turned out that basically
the the employment contract they had
said that any pet project you make the
company automatically owns like even if
you make it nights and weekends and that
sort of thing
you know we own it and so they basically
had to agree okay we didn't start
working on this until this date right
because technically technically we
wouldn't own our own our own IP
otherwise and I remember thinking that's
so draconian that's so but it dawned on
me you know the the game well you
correct me if I'm wrong on this Mike I
feel like you or a lot actually both
might have a really good insight as to
if this is a [ __ ] hypothesis or not
but it seems to me that the reason is
because you know working in music a lot
of our norms and a lot of these contract
things we're talking about it's because
the last hundred years of the music
industry and the film industry and TV
industry as a subset of that have been
working out kind of patterns that
everyone seems to be okay with and
there's a lot of precedent that sent and
it's all been essentially more or less
stemming out of Hollywood traditions the
game industry by and large emerged out
of the software industry where a single
line of code if you're designing an
operating system or if you're designing
some tool you know Microsoft Word or
something
like that it seems like a single line of
code could be the difference of you know
like a billion dollar sort of shift one
way or the other and so of course the
companies are gonna say everything that
you do we are going to own because the
stakes can be enormous Lehigh even on a
small granular level but it's not like
that really holds true over a single
line of dialogue is often not comparable
to that so the Hollywood day you're a
unique case every line of yours is a
billion dollars no but you don't I mean
it seems like it's more contentious and
it's more high risk in the software
industry in terms of the absolutely must
own what their company is producing
there should be no gray area and film is
like this cobbling together of artists
which trying to make software industry
rules for that is why we end up with
these things that feel very weird to us
does that feel like a fair assessment
yeah I think I think that's pave is
liability Bobby is like if you go and
make something offensive using the work
computer than IBM IBM mates Nazi game or
something could be a headline and
they're trying to avoid that but I think
honestly in a lot of cases it's just
it's just the complexity and and also
yeah it's often about complete
competition so like I mean Thomas was
where I've said this in interviews
before Thomas was alone was made while I
worked somewhere else and they would
have been within their rights apply I
mean the second it came out right
believed there was he maybe
conversations about that I don't Thomas
was alone only exists because one of the
the CFO of the company I worked out at
the time wrote me a letter saying we own
everything Mike Bethel makes except
Thomas was alone and it was only because
they thought Thomas was alone like
didn't make business sense they weren't
interested in taking from me and also
because they were good people getting
and very grateful for that
you know my career to that letter but
but then what was interesting was mine
when I was looking to move jobs to
another job I was still working on him
and I literally had like basically two
places I could work the place I ended up
working which was boss the studio's who
were whole had a very cool kind of we we
don't want alone it we get it
you're already making it we think it's
cool maybe talk to us when you wanna
publishing and then end up publishing
but the other place I was looking at was
a company that was making a platforming
it was a really interesting interview
because I sat down with them and I said
I'm making this little platformer that
has some kind of this was it was a it
was a big platform in franchises and I
was like it's kind of there's definitely
some links like I'm inspired by some of
the previous installments in your
franchise for some of these mechanics is
that a problem and it it really did come
down to like a polite handshake of like
there is no way legally you could ever
work for us while making that game this
is because they would be because if
because you know if I if I had an idea
in the office what's to stop me taking
that idea home with me and putting it
into my phone say like I'm sensitive to
that perspective we don't do it like all
of our employees have we have incredibly
generous kind of if you're not using if
you're not using a machine we have and
it's not work out as we our own [ __ ] but
the main reason for that is to be good
people we just don't want to like take
air and stuff but it's it's it's
actually legally more challenging to
take that stance
let's just go pocket we don't member
well exactly people don't want to have
these long paper trails and and I don't
blame them like especially you know I
know obviously the music side of it the
music side of it can get really
complicated and there's a million
different revenue sources of things to
potentially muck it all up and so yeah
it makes it makes sense that it's just
like you know what sign here and no one
ever does any forms again pretty much I
feel like as a freelancer that that can
be weird like for doing freelance
journalism sometimes and it's sometimes
there depending on how much you pitch
you can get screwed over if someone else
ever and this has happened to be twice I
pitched something they don't accept my
pitch a writer writes something
extremely similar a week later there's
no legal protection for that stuff well
I could be like well you wrote a feature
with the exact same thesis that I have
but you didn't accept my pitch for it
because you can just pay them as a
staffer like that that has happened it
with with much smaller websites to be
fair none of the big ones have done that
to me but yeah it's and it there's just
no legal protection whatsoever for
pitches and I feel like that surely that
happens in the film industry too if
someone pitches a screenplay and then
they're like don't accept that one but
my videos most studios have
clauses that say we cannot and will not
receive X start like unsolicited pitches
for that exact reason just in case you
get in trouble for something being
similar eventually yeah it's yeah you
also get you also get folks that are
like I'm gonna sue them because I'm
gonna tell them I wrote a script
similarly that Harry Potter one that's
hilarious
oh sorry Troy you're talking but I think
my muted name oh no go for it
the matrix was the same thing this
happens all the time
yeah it does well anecdotally and and
and confirmed of like stories like
high-pitched that like that that early
was my story that I pitched they're like
it's the zeitgeist man everyone's
thinking about the same thing like
there's an earthquake if there's an
asteroid if there's I can't wait to see
how many quarantine screenplays we gonna
get so it's like you can't you can't
copyright an idea yeah it's it's the
fact that was like well my character's
name was Duke my talker then you know
it's there's there's like a parity law
that exists within that but like we
really I'm just gonna say that my
favorite version of this is when you
have so often an anecdotal again
anecdotal even with no aspersions and
with no insider knowledge but often when
you get to movies that come out in the
same year that are basically the same
thing often the story is there was a
script it was doing the rounds no one
would buy it someone saw it well that's
a good idea but we don't pay for it
started making it and then the original
script got bored and so often you'll see
that way you'll see two movies they're
like this is the same I'm not going to
name any but definitely like I guess
going far enough back Armageddon and
deep there's no there's that's the
classic but it's happened a lot since
the rate didn't they come out in a
really similar period of time where it's
like you know people in a building
trying to kill each other link I mean
they all did that closely came illegally
yeah I think it was actually I think
that's a rare case didn't read come out
she much late it wasn't it wasn't it
that that the dread was kind of
obviously was referencing I feel like
they were they were in development
that's all right things they work them
at the same time I think that's a thing
but that's the thing that I also may
have just heard from a friend that isn't
I feel like there was enough space that
like the makers of Dredd were like no we
did we were inspired it's cool was 2012
that's pretty close
pretty close pretty close but yeah I
love that and but obviously I wouldn't
love that if I lose telescreen right
yeah but it's no we're like like yeah
you're absolutely right the reason we we
have that protection of kind of you we
will not receive a script yeah if
someone sends me a game design that's
actually happens to me quite a bit where
people like dad me going hey I'm working
on a game can you give me your feedback
I'm like I can't look at I can't
I'm not able to click on that link icon
even basic knowledge I noticed you send
me isn't that a thing where like game
mechanics can't be copy written yeah I
do Junction but it's it says it's not
that it's copy writing to be honest I
would say probably the bigger risk to
someone in my positions is the
reputational damage than legal right you
can prove you can you could win or lose
any kind of copyright case you weren't
win or lose depending on how much
money's in the bank account like the the
real risk to me is when someone says a
young Mike Biddle stole my idea that's
that that's the one I'm trying to avoid
at all times I you know a perfect you
know perfect example of that that
happened years ago that that actually
ties together a lot of these sort of
threads is the when there's the composer
Tyler Bates who has known a lot of Zack
Snyder's stuff and he was and John wick
obviously and he was hired yeah he was
hired to do the 300 you know he and Zack
signer did the Dawn of the Dead sort of
remake and referencing the the chant
that hasn't happened and then the 300
came after that and what happened was
I'm ever seeing the film actually
weirdly I saw that movie with Jenova
Chen it's hilarious just to think of
that combo in my mind
and saw I saw obviously a tangent uh I
think it's called superstar The Lonely
Island Molly Shannon movie no
minute-long
I saw popstar never stop never stopping
with Walt Williams okay who if anyone
who doesn't know wrote spec ups like
written on that's a bunch of video games
I saw that movie with him in the cinema
with Walt Williams watching pop star
never stop never stopping or whatever it
is he like have a shot never stopping he
did that movie is underrated I love that
film I've seen that film like at least
I'm very funny sides in that film why
the VIP works only our notes them I
believe well that's an interesting case
right we're lonely island our eggs are
an entity that exists outside of SNL I
think I don't know like the legal side
of it but I remember seeing an interview
Andy Samberg where it was like we are a
separate thing we lice I think they
license the music to SNL is like a I
believe exit this is what I'm saying
even SNL doesn't more worried about
music really complicated yeah exactly
count on that being the reason why it
could be that they that that was a
leveraged negotiation where they
basically said look we know these things
are gonna be viral hits and and we will
continue making them for you but we will
you know we will retain the rights I
could very much see that if things reach
a certain level of popularity you
definitely gained the ability I have no
clue if that's the case but it it's not
automatically the truth at SNL was like
this too complicated
yeah they must have a lot of complicated
stuff with with jokes and writing and
talent and how those people are all
allowed to do their own stand-up and I
don't see it that seems complicated for
sure but we've almost been live for two
hours so
the problem yeah Troy sorry that like I
feel like we we spoken of you just cuz
this weird muting thing is happening I'm
noticing if people are not realizing
you're speaking cuz your voice is not
coming in I don't know how that's
happened what yeah yeah yeah where
because you when you're like I said when
you're starting a sentence it's like not
your muted for us for some reason is
that still happening right now well I
will if we talk seems to be what it is
he's like some kind of noise is he there
I didn't hear anything you said because
I was talking that's just that's just
zoom happening maybe you'll need to
learn manners oh yeah I'm actually at
the point I need to start moving on to
my next thing I've got something it
starts in about eight minutes okay thank
you everyone for joining us live did
also want to say thank you to Adam whom
also donated said congrats on your tenth
episode thank you so much um for
everyone who's wondering I'm going to
basically like unlist the live stream
and then published tomorrow so that
everyone gets it at a standard time the
audio version will be an edited version
so if you're worried about any of that
stuff we'll grab that and in terms of
doing another light up light up so we
might do one for episode 20 maybe but
that's very far away it's not something
that I want to do too frequently because
we enjoy it unless we take this daily
right we now own that everyone in the
shadow insider bit oh yeah everyone
underestimated just how harsh a Lana's
contract was for us even have that
awkwardness when using someone on my
channel where I always want to be like
is this okay can I use this image of you
I recently edited a smile on to Mike's
face for a thumbnail without still are
telling him I only told him afterwards
said you look so nice in this picture
and I didn't correct
I didn't say that's not even me that's
somebody else anything else like you
were smiling because I was like this is
too sad it's about mental health we
can't people in these spaces I was a
scientist man yeah
it was just like who's too dramatic
thumbnail thank you for joining us live
everyone we really appreciate it sorry
we didn't talk about Final Fantasy I
swear to God I had a whole plan about
remakes and IPs and now I'm gonna have
to title this something to do with legal
it's happened again stall was Clone Wars
it's very good faster Edition yeah still
there's a varsity course play watch
listen yeah um yeah what do you all be
up on all the audio services tomorrow
and otherwise we will see you guys next
week
[Music]